is there any mistake that you made early
on in your career that you said never
again and it's not so much working with
someone or whatever it's more something
either you did or something you didn't
pick up on about a situation that cost
you and you said I will never I was
offered a role I'm not gonna tell you
the roles it was a TV show I tell us
payment playing this role that I did not
like I think it was an embarrassing role
of a pimp but I have been trying to get
a job in TV for like three years and
couldn't get anything rejection
rejection reject so for this role
audition and I got the wrong and friends
of mine saw the script they said don't
do it totally broke meant let's do I
able to give me some something it was a
hit TV show - I did I did it I saw the
footage I said oh my god nobody sees
this and maybe five to seven years later
when I had some real money I called the
network and tried to buy I tried to buy
the footage back that I was in and to
buy the episode and I said I'd pay
whatever they it wouldn't sell it to me
that's how I see him that was but
David the money they did the job haven't
done it since them but I understand and
before that is to put down on the
step-in Fetchit I just put down through
that came before me that did you know
they smiled laughing dancing didn't
tackle like you know happy black people
then maids and butlers and stuff under
their shaming the race and then no no
they took the jobs that were offered to
them at that time to do the best that
they could of what they had and my
respect for them changed totally because
I was faced with the same thing I could
understand why they did what they did
but I was fortunate enough not to have
to do it again I have had to do it sense
but and I still get these opportunities
but to turn down something mechanical a
lot of money a lot of people would see
but it's totally against everything you
stand for as an actor and artist and
everything I mean certain people put
down certain people because of what they
did in the show or whatever or not I
don't I don't do that anymore I just say
you don't know their circumstance you
got a sick baby at home you got a sick
baby at home
gotta take care of the bills I don't
know his business I am not fond of
reality TV though I got I'm not gonna
lie I was in out of the country and I
was asked questions about my culture
based on middle a lady TV and I was
saying know it that's not the way every
black person in the world not every
black person's women dragged across the
if it was to flirt by their hair and and
every black man wears his pants below
his butt
we thought all blacks said no because we
were looking at your pants we wonder why
you didn't have your pierced this in
Belgium when you you stopped them one
guy at the restaurant not nothing
against Belgium but I was just wondering
if it was the same trip like not this
one I was in China years ago that was in
China that was in China and I was in
Japan and Tokyo and they just it said
there's something wrong with me because
I didn't look like the regular black
people he said you speak good - did they
know your work some of them did but at
that time not a lot of them they just oh
you're here filming oh good good I have
some questions for you you know I was in
shotgun away but not in the way you know
because I know the stuff that gets to
them that's how they see us as a culture
and I just was amazed by how many people
followed us that way but media is very
powerful and that's whatever they see
that's who you are
you